in Avengers endgame we saw a nose wailed
a massive double bladed sword in fact we
saw it in some leaks and in some
trailers before the movie even came out
how's it going everybody it's Warren and
there are many questions in regards to
famous a sword a sword that from what it
looked like in Avengers in game is
basically indestructible a sword so
strong that it even broke Captain
America shield which is made out of
vibranium which is supposed to be the
strongest metal on earth so if Thanos
has sword broke Captain America shield
what exactly is it made of and where did
they nose get it well the Russo brothers
who directed Avengers infinity war and
Avengers in game have weighed in on this
I'll break down what they said in this
video but first if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe I'm doing a
massive giveaway at 400,000 subscribers
I'm picking three winners and each will
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection that they want
since the movie came out many people
have been asking the Russo brothers
where Thanos got a sword and what
exactly is it made out of and in a
recent interview they finally weighed in
on the question and they said clearly
Fanus is a thousand-year-old character
who has fought everyone in the universe
and is the greatest he's the Genghis
Khan of the universe so he would have
the greatest weapon he knows of III he's
been to treet to have his glove created
did he have them create his blade as
well potentially but it's interesting
that it could destroy the shield and
obviously the shield is referring to
Captain America shield when he broke it
in Avengers endgame the Russo brothers
do not directly answer this question
which they obviously know the answer to
because they are the directors of the
movie and had the sword in the movie but
they do majorly hint that the sword is
indeed made out of room metal the same
metal that Thor's axe Stormbreaker is
made out of in the same metal that his
hammer Mjolnir is made out of this makes
perfect sense because earu metal is
supposed to be the strongest metal in
the universe and remember that Thanos
had the Infinity Gauntlet for a very
long time when he had the Infinity
Gauntlet made he didn't go for the
stones himself he hired other people to
get them for him so the Russo brothers
hinting that Eitri actually made the
sword for Thanos as well as the Infinity
Gauntlet makes sense in the first
Avengers movie Captain America was able
to block Thor's hammer Mjolnir with his
shield but keep in mind Thor's hammer
wasn't a blade it wasn't sharp
so yes Thor's hammer did not break
Captain America's shield and the first
of
Jers movie but it also wasn't a sharp
blade that could pierce into the shield
like fan osis sword but the blade has to
be made out of a stronger metal than
vibranium because like the Russo
brothers said it's interesting that it
could destroy the shield and yo metal is
definitely stronger than vibranium
so although the Risso brothers don't
give us a direct answer it seems like
they are indirectly telling us that
thanasis sword is made out of uru metal
and that Eitri did make it for him but
let me know what you all think about
this in the comments down below and
again be sure to subscribe at the
400,000 subscriber mark I'll be picking
three winners to pick one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection that
they want there will be multiple ways to
enter and win that I will explain later
but you must be subscribed to my channel
to enter the giveaway be sure to drop a
like if you enjoyed this video and be
sure to let me know what you think about
it in the comments down below as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]